this is going to take us to a very very
big journey of the simple kinds of
quadratics that you've already met my
end of last term and even earlier than
that actually but now we're sort of
diving into the deep end of what
quadratics can do so let's start at the
top because that's the easiest question
right it's nice it's monic it's easily
factorize able and you want to give me
the factorization for that first
question anyone what's the pair of
numbers we're looking for me it's going
to be three and seven I but to get a
minus ten their tune I need negative 3
and negative seven right they'll add to
that we and they will multiply because
the negatives will cancel each other
yeah so being at negative 3 negative 7
on what I want negative 3 look this is
not going to last long as what the
market tender 3 negative 7 there's my
factorization okay and I'll use that to
come up with my solutions I know I
didn't say you know solve it but when
you see something like this is not much
else you can do with it really okay so
if you remember this this is something
times something is 0 so if you've got a
paradigm thing applies 0l is one of them
has to be 0 right so if this one is 0
what's w equal to its going to be 3 and
if the other one is 0 then the other
interest salmon don't home and host okay
so that was nice and easy to begin with
when you have a look at question 2 i'm
going to something time it's not money
right so you've got now a whole bunch of
tools at your disposal to solve a
question like this but being that this
one says complete the square and this
sign says quadratic can we try to factor
izes can we try not to resort to these
other methods what am I going to do here
I'm still searching for a pair of
numbers right but it's slightly
different what parent what all i want my
pair of numbers to do i wanted them for
four to add to this amount part of this
so this question i still want them to
add to that but what do I want them to
multiply to your bedtime yeah in this
case negative 24 right so you think okay
maybe of 24 that's what I want them to
multiply to just forget about the other
side for a second just think of your
factory
right so what do you fact is we get 24
small enough we can point you all
effectives right you won by 24 what's
another pair of factors six and four
what's another pair of fact is eight and
three and we're missing one more right
to 12 okay now you have a look at those
and now we bring out a negative into the
internet weeks right I'm sorry yeah yeah
okay I want a pair of these and they're
going in to differ by 10 right because
when i add them together I should get 10
and one will be negative okay so which
of these differ by 10 it's going to be
the last one right 2 and 12 2 and 12 so
it will be minus 2 times 12 or two x
minus 12 which one do you think is going
to be negative that they're going to add
up to 10 right which is positive so I
want the bigger number to be positive so
it looks like I want negative 2 and 12
that'll do it for me let's just check
because we went through a whole bunch of
pressure set negative 2 plus 12 dad will
give you 10 negative 2 times 12 now give
me my minus 24 are you happy with that
ok so now I have my pair of numbers
minus 2 and 12 what am I going to do
with them again regret deeply yeah good
I'm going to take this 10a in the middle
and I want to break it into two pieces
okay so one of the pieces is going to go
up the front and the other piece is
going to go at the back what do you guys
reckon do you reckon the 12 should go
this way the record should go this way
to the right to the right shall we try
it to the right okay so i'm going to
write a squared minus 2e right and
you're suggesting I should put the 12 e
on the right hand side minus 3 don't
worry if this ends up not being helpful
we'll find out pretty quickly and then
we'll just try it the other way let's
have a look now I have two pairs yeah
pier 1 pier to what can I take out of
the first pair I can take out to eat
good so when I do that that leaves me
with a 40 there and just a minus 1 good
okay now does this look like it's going
to work over here what factor am I going
to take out plus 3 which leaves you with
40 minus 1
okay so we have that same pair there
that's how we know we went on the right
track okay so now I can I've got my 40-1
that's common and what do I get left
with what's going to be factorized out
of 28 posts very very good i hope the
bells of st. a ring when you see
something like this even if you couldn't
make it all the way through that and now
I just do what I did before I set this
to be 0 and then see what happens and
then I said that busier and see what
happens can anyone read off those
answers for me feedback the first one
when we're going to chuck in here to
make this 0 if you've got a couple ways
right you want me this whole thing 0 so
if this whole thing is 0 then this part
before eight will just be one right
because it'll be one minus one is zero
so what value will make this this one
it'll be a quarter right because four
times a quarter will be 1 1-1 that case
p 0 so a corner is my first submission
right and then I'm going to do the same
thing here moves through I want to
administer into it very good it has to
be negative so that this is negative
this is positive and they cancel and
you're going to have to multiply my two
so you want this to be divided by two
and you're done and you could check it
if you like you can pop both of those
back in here movie right